[Music]
do you think that God knows what's
happening oh yeah what was what
pandemic you could totally tell when
he's jumping around in the martini
teachin what's happening that's not what
I'm saying no he's he's so I think he's
just so oblivious right now he's just
still in his like this this is my house
and we do all these fun activities every
day yeah I didn't expect him to I did
expect it one thing he one thing that I
do that I think he does recognize a
little bit more is so he doesn't see
grandma that much so when he sees like
when we FaceTime grandma I get really
excited or even heard my dad's voice
that one time I got really excited and
then the other day I went to go take
them to pick up some food and then as
we're walking out the door because I
think his routine if we're gonna get and
dad's truck we're gonna go hiking so he
saw who were walking out the door he saw
her going on dad's truck he's like I
can't thank you I'm like no I'm not
going hiking the trails are closed did
he understand what you meant no who's
just like this is still happy wait and
better what you meant I know I [ __ ] up
how about your kitties do they know
what's happening I set them down explain
it to them perfect
was it getting plucked she knows right
oh yeah so much use well also i sat down
my water machine and then whispered it
into the bed you should sure we're gonna
do it I should yeah I'll sit down and
cost it on the water machine and you sit
down type of answer yeah explain to both
them at the same time if you want to
thank you oh you know unless Bart you
want I gonna suddenly enter the real
world and it's like it's like a car has
been moving at 60 miles an hour and then
it goes to zero so there's this article
on Psychology Today that explores how
like should parents pretend everything's
perfectly fine in the world right now or
lie
keep the kid [ __ ] in the shadows as
much as possible well you know what if
they actually they say is kids can tell
when parents are trying to suppress
their stress because they are sorry
actors
and they're hiding Daniel day-lewis is
care Danny loses kids like I don't know
for a while we lived in 1800 my dad was
praying for Lincoln for the longest time
I thought we were you know I had to call
him and have all thing what if he makes
his whole family act that era too so
he's like a real method meant that I his
six-year-old knows how to use alone his
wife irons clothes with a real [ __ ]
iron that you warm up and [ __ ] over the
fire yeah he's like Abigail why did you
shave your [ __ ] all true your loins
sorry
wide I must shave bye Louis oh that's
good that was really good
your New England clam Boston oyster yeah
so they're just saying that the new
research suggests that overtly
suppressing parental emotions in an
attempt to protect children from
emotional distress may actually you just
backfire she could have been a better
liar well or you could just cuz they
brought mom's body got my scalp [ __ ]
gone - she's crying sheep would be doing
that [ __ ] no so this study's goal is to
examine if parents stress responses are
transmitted to their 7 to 11 year old
children on a psychological level we
could feel it like with their emotional
suppression they it actually affects the
children the behavioral dynamics between
parent and child and so they're just
same like you just got to figure out a
way to communicate that [ __ ] be there
for your child validate your child's
emotions so like for example with Isaac
right now he's like really bummed out
that he didn't get to say goodbye to his
his sixth grade friends because he's
changing schools next year and then he's
just like really down about that and so
you know we've been trying to like
validate him by
but you're saying like yeah of course a
man and that [ __ ] sucks like that's
crazy like you don't get to see your
friends like these are some crazy times
like and then like we try to like help
them a bit by being like well it's the
positive like you know on the positive
side you you get to play video games all
day and like you get to FaceTime your
friends whenever you can so that's kind
of good but but it's like being there
for them and letting them express their
emotions and then if we're stressed out
like I don't think I've really hit it
from him home like especially that one
time when I kind of got like a mini
panic attack you didn't have any food in
the house and when this all first
started I didn't really like hide that
from him I was just like yeah man I'm so
glad we're getting groceries now because
I was really panicking like it's really
scary to not have no I kind of feel that
because when I got back home from Europe
right I'd have any food in the house
yeah cuz I was like [ __ ] cuz what's the
point groceries are gonna go bad and I'm
like but do I go out now cuz I'm
supposed to quarantine so [ __ ] I had to
go get some food but it was it was I
never had that ever yeah he's like food
should I get it or not
yeah because my mom could not keep it
together day by day just because of all
stress and [ __ ] but then like if
something like 9/11 happened she's like
Steven everything's gonna be completely
fine for like these crazy moments but
then day to day I'm like yeah you're a
mess it's fine I love you it's fine
love like she broke a plate then it was
over yeah right exactly exactly you
should have done what all of our parents
did and as soon as Isaac starts crying
about something you start competing with
him on his soul rules you just say you
think missing your [ __ ] graduation is
tough what about when Reem is we don't
have our jobs [ __ ]
oh you don't you know you're gonna miss
your sixth-grade friends not really
validating anymore guys you're going
backwards
that's ways to be saying hey that's
better why
oh you're gonna miss your sixth-grade
friends I lost friends in the Vietnam
War
good your toe I got shot in the face no
did your parents make you feel better
when they did that with you no but look
at how successful I am it's great what
you say anything like that but you also
look like that with handlebars maybe for
all the people out there your parents
should have compared themselves to you
more
you know everyone had that I had to walk
2 miles to school every day [ __ ]
lying-ass mom you didn't have to walk
two miles for [ __ ] you took the Train
you ain't standing but you took the
train you know where this is going right
it's not gonna be I had to walk two
miles for us it's gonna be I had to
drive to school and then the kids like
what you didn't just sit in your room on
computer and you're at school I have to
get ready to go to school I couldn't
just get up in my pajama and do online
school look what that's [ __ ] crazy
yeah myself I have to dress both halves
of my body yeah I'm not stupid show me
pictures then just the top right here so
if you're stressed and just say I'm fine
that only makes you less available to
your child's we found that the kids
picked up on that and reciprocated which
became a self-fulfilling dynamic so then
like now your children will no longer be
able to connect with you because that's
true they've learned that you are
unavailable to them so they will not be
available to you no crying little [ __ ]
that's true I don't depend on my parents
for anything oh not even emotion see me
too actually
yeah like for nothing right if anything
they rely on me for a mortgage yeah here
we go toward town so maybe that method
is better that's right
rocket are we still involved in this
conversation
[Laughter]
and then he starts playing piano that's
him at home right now I can just
visually we're all just a hallucination
that's pretty funny though the whole
what how you should deal with the kids
during a court date and like I feel like
I feel like people now care so [ __ ]
much about not hurting their kids
feelings where I'm just comparing it to
our parents generations who didn't give
a [ __ ] they're just like so busy they
don't have time for that [ __ ] but
our generation is just like oh man like
how do we break it to them we do the
opposite of maybe over coddling maybe or
I don't know dude their generation saw
JFK die on TV that's true and they're
like and they had the Zapruder tape they
saw this [ __ ] over and over and over
again so it's like I don't even know how
that works I mean we all saw 9/11 on TV
yeah and we saw the Towers fall and all
that [ __ ] I mean it's the active shooter
[ __ ] on TV right and so sometimes this
[ __ ] just happens live and you're just
there for it for the maximum conflict
and you're seeing it and that's okay
that's like hope you can help you I mean
I like I like what this articles saying
right it's always like your feelings are
valid and you guys should talk about it
cuz even when that [ __ ] happen it's like
it was bad but we're not gonna talk
about the bad part of it we're only
gonna focus on the good part
you know patriotism but we're not gonna
talk about any of the bad stuff that's
like watching the love making scenes in
a movie where like my parents were just
we just all kind of maybe like want to
look know ours is just we just all
looked away so we're never talked
through it or anything we just pretended
like anything else uncomfortable just
didn't exist yeah and then so you end up
being on you available for it and you
know you can't go to your parents about
sex because they're just as awesome as
you are same exact you know what my mom
did every time a love scene came on she
went whoa that's what you want don't you
that's hilarious that's what my grandpa
I was like I do what that was like [ __ ]
cuz we were watching the movie the saint
without Coomer and there's a love scene
it and belle Kimber is like putting the
business of some chick and I was like
[ __ ] all this stuff don't look away
you're like pansy I was trying to make
my grandpa know that I wasn't looking
because that's what my parents wanted
right or whatever and my grandpa's like
what your parents do all this [ __ ]
you're probably make him embarrassed by
going by bashful about exactly true and
that's good it's good just be honest
yeah it's only weird if you make it
weird yeah every time I parents covered
my eyes for those I'd be I'd move just
enough when one of my eyes I still see
my yep mm-hmm watching it's not mad oh
no they're making love which with each
other they have a good healthy
relationship no for me was always for
kisses like just for a kiss
yeah really that [ __ ] up my friend he
still can't watch people kiss on in
movies and he's like he's like 27 he
can't get some anxiety of it just kind
of looks away every time I'm like what
are you doing you're an adult no I took
it a little weird a little awkward you
look away literally it could be in the
room completely alone and there's like
the sex scene that pops up and I'm like
do I have to watch is it cuz it feels
voyeuristic like you're watching someone
else's sexy times I don't know I think
it's because of a childhood trauma like
I don't know it's like I fast-forward
cuz it's never as good as the pornos
that's why I don't really watch porn
weird
I do sometimes I'm normal good for you
but it's lesbian right not always [ __ ]
anymore oh good for you you're from you
moved on I mean I haven't one point is
like [ __ ] forever cuz you have actual
port right I saw Laura Croft Tomb Raider
getting pounded in an ad the other day
[Music]